アッパ
のん
延長教授です
私の進行している科目は炎上学
ネットやテレビいろんな場所で林蔵する方
今のでたくさんいらっしゃると思いますがそういった人たちも塩蔵
に至るかでのアルゴリズムや内容を規定となったきっかけ
おったどうすればそれじゃ
退場するが震撼するまた
塩蔵せないようにその心がけることずっとがポイント予防法などし日研究している雄2
羽大学名誉教授ってん状況でです
京響
よろしくお願い致します現代の人類の子供たちは事業とよりやっぱりアプリの5件
アプリのが面白いと思うので今日は
アプリあたりをみんなで彫ってこうやっていこう
[音楽]
だ許可しないといっ
かはいというわけで生徒の皆さんさっそくやっていきましょう
こんなこんなアプリがありましたネット炎上事件も炎上をしたことを
後年があふれにした未来ですそのとおりですねと言うとかさっそく
早速やってみましょうどんなというか全くわからないんですけど大いきなり
正解数炎上の問題がアプリになっているんですね
これをやれば誰でも過去の事例から炎上をどうしたらなくなる
どうすれば映像しなくなったのかの予防の仕方がわかるのでぜひ sns やってる
からとか
インター twitter やって来たユーチューバーの方ティックトックカードは誰
でもいいのでとりあえず見たを言った方がいいかもですね
はい
受けてだけで早速を助けていきましょう住所までですね
住所がでよくありますが某ユーチューバー肇社長のいえば鈴鹿月頭おかしい
完全にばれてるみたいとかいます皆が来て狂うことがないようにお気を付け下さいはい
クエスト日俳優の愛子ちゃんの sns はフォロワー数が10万を超えていて
投稿に皆が興味精神今日投稿をさっそくチェックしてみると表示されてはいけない情報
が
ああ
これは良くないんですねえ
おっとポケモンゴーの卵の要請がこれはああああ
みてください見てください visa ポチャンと仕事終わりに写真のところで後ろに
炎上はいという建物が見えますね炎上はい2ですねたの援助ハイツという建物を調べれ
ばきっともの
木村亜矢子さんの住所はすぐ分かりますね簡単ですロケッちーの近くの美味で一人で
リセットタイムのアイコさんのサングラスの奥に
bouvet ちょちょいきにょどうだろうあなぁ1回答え見てみましょうあ
なるほどなるほど答えですね
自宅デート書かれた投稿よく見てみると位置情報が表示されています致命的な設定ミス
ですね
弱ですと列柱っていうのに位置情報が載っているとそこが自宅てバレてしまいますから
これよくないですねこの前の投稿で自宅の住所が特定されてしまったアイコさんは
ひっそりと引っ越しをしたみたいなのに彼女の投稿にはまだ自宅を特定されてしまう
あるものが高
で多分
ここじゃないですかね
大
ちょっと詰めて私炎上につい敏感なもので
先読みしてしまいましたねふぅ
夫婦です
これもわかるダイニングで仕事が忙しくすれ違いないと公言してライブだったけど彼女
以前ですかでしょ町大字二本木4作決定的な証拠がこれはさっき私がいいと思うんです
もう予選年先読みしすぎて全部を買ってしまいますこれぞ
えっ上こいつ方ですこの前は楽しかった
コンサートのレポ記事が出ていたので早速チェック写真もたくさんのって嬉しいただ
一人なぜか
悪目立ちしている人がいてああ
これはアイドルのライブの写真の投稿ですね
左下の女は何 rainbow けんぴを持っとるには分かりません謎が多いですね
パリですね実際行ったことある人じゃないと定石っていうのはわかりませんから
アイドルのライブが果たしてどれぐらいでもなかなか墓地と私はわかりかねない言葉が
ありますが多分徴兵ピースしては内輪のせいで後ろの人が見えなくなるかもしれません
あっ違うんだ1人なのがばれ面接している人が入っ
この人かなん
このリボンかなさってもあぁデカすぎるリボンは多分後ろの人の邪魔になってしまい
ますね
これよくないですねこのんだは援助しない記念品 faster にルール違反
あっこの芋けんぴおんがみんな我慢している柵を越えてにも原皮を取り入っているよ
つば援助しますね国わけでスターか
メンバーが目の前に来ていると言う
シシ汁が嬉しいけど興奮しても故意的な一線があるのです
あっあみてください皆さん緑色エコアイドル強
掴まれていますこれよくないですあーもうコンサート自体を妨害してますから
一ちょいでやってしまっていても証拠が残ってしまいますので現場につながってしまう
金やあり now our これもば買ったですね多分
やばいこれマジでやばいアイス図を見て下さい入ってる人がいますでもう位ターン制で
昔これやった人
やばすぎでしょうこれもっと悪いことするんですね
あっモーターていんさー頭を田施設でちゃんっ
ダメですよね
でもいるんだよこういうことする人本当にまずでずんずん前
もうこの男の子ですねこれ駄目ですねを前にちょいたダメですけども
やらお腹減っていただきますん
ここに誤ってこちらは来ねえ店内で食ってるよ私上でもいるんですよ
雇用だねとなるから行ってみたらこれはもう完全に輸注バーですねマジで危ないから
止めろ
スマホ上げてみた
どこかの湯つばが
スマホ上げてた人いいましたねこれ自体な危ないでしょうね
阿部ない道がよくないですよ
はいやばい
物を粗末に扱う
ユーチューバーみたいですよね極端に物を粗末にする小岩
叩かれやすいです
皆さんに気をつけましょう
in 発を10時過ぎて極端にものを育てにするように客を立てると叩かれやすいので
注意しましょう俺だ
[音楽]
me
バッハ